übermorgen ende denn frankfurt die
internationale automobil ausstellung iaa
früher wissen sie ein hochamt für jeden
echten deutschen heute schauplatz eines
gnadenlosen kulturkampfes gegen das auto
ja da in frankfurt wurde ich muss es so
sagen offene kritik an autoindustrie und
verbrennungsmotor geübt schlimm schlimm
wenn wir so weiter machen prophezeit
wenn wir so weitermachen dann stirbt die
deutscheste aller erfindung das auto
bald den märtyrertod meldungen und
herren ja
es muss auch mal wehtun ja
das war heftig da in frankfurt und
einige demo bilder waren für mich
regelrecht verstörend draußen also die
forderung nach einer neuen
verkehrspolitik und einer beschneidung
der macht der autokonzerne geil
doppelauspuff und ich verstehe die wut
der demonstranten ich verstehe die wut
wirklich aber es tut sich doch was auf
der iaa zeigen sie zum beispiel der frau
merkel nur noch die stände mit den
geilsten e-autos und sie ist voll
begeistert also im rahmen ihrer
möglichkeiten dass auch dieses segment
eine nachhaltige und gute zukunft hat
wikileaks nach zukunft aus
sid nach zukunft aus ein satz den man
über angela merkel immer seltener hört
meine damen und herren 40 jahren was
politisch
sie will damit auch schauen
konkret zu den fakten 40 jahren vor
vielen jahren hätte die autoindustrie
konsequent in alternative antriebsformen
investieren müssen und der staat
natürlich in den öpnv
heute gibt's keine schnellen lösungen
sie haben in einem land mit 11 millionen
pendlern den verbrenner übermorgen
verbieten zu wollen ist mindestens naiv
wie will man denn das auto auf die
schnelle ersetzen mit innovativer
technik die mobilität der zukunft hat
bereits begonnen
fantastisch brauche ich das ding kann
mit meiner frau sonntags die fahrradtour
machen und es ist ja völlig okay es ist
völlig okay dass viele deutsche ihr auto
lieben warum denn nicht natürlich das
sind gefühle dann kann keiner was dafür
problematisch ist nur wie breit sich die
teile inzwischen machen vor allem in
unseren städten in berlin überlegen sie
mal gehen 19 prozent der öffentlichen
verkehrsfläche allein für parkplätze
drauf 19 prozent oder anderes beispiel
in münchen haben sie die parkgebühren
seit 2004 gar nicht mehr erhöht im
selben zeitraum ist aber der pnv bis zu
60 prozent teurer geworden
klar nehmen viele dann lieber das auto
obwohl hier gerade ein anderes auto
abgeschleppt wird parken schon wieder
die nächsten hier falsch es für uns
nicht unangenehm
ich finde wenn eine echte argumente hat
ist es okay oder
dann ist es okay und ich sage ihnen wenn
wir unsere innenstädte wirklich vom auto
zurück erobern wollen dann muss parken
teurer werden ein anwohner ausweis
kostet zb in amsterdam 535 und den
stockholm sogar 827 euro pro jahr
in berlin sind 20 euro 40 für zwei jahre
ja ja und man könnte mehr für fahrräder
machen sowie in utrecht während es bei
uns für radfahrer jeden tag heißt
nightmare on elm street haben die da
drüben eigene fahrer parkhäuser deshalb
steckt richtig 130 euro pro kopf wie die
infrastruktur für den radverkehr
zum vergleich in berlin sind es vier
euro 70 wahnsinn vier euro 70 dafür
kriegst du berlin drei löhner in utrecht
beheizen die im winter fahrrad brücken
damit sich keiner auf die fresse liegt
und was haben wir cdu-politiker die
knöllchen an radler verteilen wollen er
will dass fahrradfahrer genau wie
autofahrer parkscheine ziehen müssen um
eine gleichbehandlung der
verkehrsteilnehmer wollen dann kann es
nicht sein dass der ein oder andere nur
gekümmert wird und der andere ist alles
schuld geben
das wäre übrigens auch ein gutes
wahlplakat cdu wimpern alle wenn es so
wäre
[Applaus]
ja
november alle gleich gepampert würden
autofahren wird bei uns jedes jahr mit
88 milliarden euro subventioniert 88
milliarden fahrradverkehr meines wissens
nicht
andererseits ich behaupte die
allermeisten deutschen haben doch
verstanden dass sich bei uns im land im
verkehr ja wirklich was ändern muss ich
war jeden morgen mit 600 ps statt dass
man auch weiterhin und jetzt sogar ist
recht so ja ja das sind gerade die
extreme in der diskussion
die einen wollen weiter mit 600 ps im
nagelstudio balon die gerade die andern
wollen am liebsten nächste woche alle
suvs in deutschland verbieten wenn das
so weitergeht sind dicke karin schon
bald gesellschaftlich so geächtet dass
sie in freier wildbahn gar nicht mehr
vorkommen
dann müssen wir perversen die trotzdem
noch auf spd stehen in so ja ein so
zwielichtige garagen gehen wo sie dann
für ein homie zehn minuten lang ihre
krankenauto erotischen fantasien
ausleben dürfen
[Musik]
es polarisiert der streit ums auto geht
weiter und vor allem die sehr aufgeregte
diskussion um den suv reißt einfach
nicht ab
aber das kennen wir jetzt freunde vor
gericht ganz nicht willkommen am
landgericht köln mülheim
angeklagt ist ein sogenanntes sport
utility vehicle kurz suv ruhe bitte das
schlussviertel gegen die verteidigung
hält albrecht humboldt danke frage
worüber reden wir hier was ist denn
eigentlich ein suv hier bei uns gelten
witz kisten wie der opel mutter oder der
dacia duster als geländefahrzeug
höher gelegte bobby cars
lächerlich suv beginnt für mich wenn ich
auf der landstraße einfach durch den
hirsch durchfahren ohne was zu merken
wie durch butter echte suvs sind direkte
nachfahren des panzers mit dem unsere
großväter damals die abkürzung durch
holland genommen haben und eine welt
eine welt ohne suvs möchte ich mir keine
sekunde vorstellen allein die deutsche
rap szene könnte morgen dicht machen
rapper brauchen die im alltag ständig
wenn ich jetzt ein großeinkauf habe oder
was weiß ich was ich machen soll das
alles auch mit gepackten ist ja so eine
sache da hilft so ist wie sehr viel zum
einkaufen so spielen keine ahnung die
autos gibt schon seit tausenden von
jahren
natürlich es gibt sogar stiche die
zeigen wie annie ball mit seinem
landrover über die alpen kacheln
wie diese abkürzung steht für sicherheit
und kann die überlebenschancen bei einem
unfall sind in einem suv siebenmal höher
also jetzt für den darin setzt sich für
die die wir hatten noch fußgänger genau
absolute alibi diskussion wenn überhaupt
müssen wir über zu viele autos sprechen
gh es gibt bei uns zu viele autos weil
die leider zum preis wert sind und sich
zu viele menschen einst leisten können
da lobe ich mir den suv von bentley und
da gibt es tolle angebote aber so in der
größenordnung bei 160000 euro bis ende
das wäre ein mögliches top automobil
haben möchte in dem segment der kann
bislang nur maximal 160 tausend euro
ausgeben
genau dieses problem lösen wie jetzt
danke
endlich jemand der probleme löst aber
mein finales argument jedes land hat die
autos die es verdient seit 1990 sind
unsere im schnitt um zwölf zentimeter
breiter geworden autos werden also vom
design immer hässlicher und gleichzeitig
immer fetter und damit meine damen und
herren sind sie ein perfekter spiegel
der deutschen gesellschaft vielen dank
ja
bei mir geht schnell oliver welke für
die anklage meine damen und herren herr
kollege
in deutschland gibt es laut
kraftfahrtbundesamt 3,1 millionen
zugelassene suv aber komischerweise nur
15.000 förster das heißt für drei
millionen 85.000 suvs gibt es eigentlich
keine entschuldigung auch nicht für
meinen die sitzung ist geschlossen
wurden haben
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal